[MUSIC PLAYING]
BADER HAMDAN: So welcome.
Good morning.
Good afternoon.
Good evening for the
folks on the livestream.
My name is Bader Hamsan.
I am part of the
Google Cloud team,
and I lead our backup disaster
recovery partnerships.
So my role is to build a
deliberate data protection
portfolio strategy
with our partners
and our internal
teams, as well as a go
to market for execution.
So a little fun fact about me.
I actually jumped from a plane.
I did skydiving.
My wife hated it I
actually didn't tell her
I was going to do
it until I did.
So I definitely
need a backup plan.
And just-- so notice it's
called backup, archive,
and disaster recovery.
That's an acronym for BADR.
Actually probably-- I was told--
I was told I should change
my name and remove the E,
and it's just a
perfect match so.
Awesome.
So welcome everybody.
We're going to get going here.
We're going to start with a
little bit about cloud data
protection and the cloud
opportunity and then go--
and they talk about
the partner landscape.
So we have partnerships
that we work with,
industry leading
partnerships to drive
these solutions, backup archive
and DR solutions to market.
Then I'm going to invite up
on stage several partners
and customers to
actually give examples
of how these solutions are
actually practically leveraging
in GCP right now.
And we'll hear from their
experiences and their journeys
as they adopt a Google Cloud
and the partner solution
for these specific use cases.
And then we'll wrap it up.
Does that sound like a plan?
Awesome.
All right, we'll get going.
So we all know the
data is growing.
Per IDC data is going to grow
to 175 zetabytes by 2025.
Just to give you as context,
that is $175 billion terabytes.
That's a lot of data 440% growth
of data compared to last year's
alone.
And what is 175 comprised of?
42 of that capacity will be
shipping over the next seven
years.
90 zetabytes of data will be
created by IoT Devices by 2025.
We've heard about IoT devices
and sensors creating data.
That data is just part of it.
And by 2025, 49% of the data
will be stored in Cloud--
in a public cloud environment.
And again, this is
according to an ADC report
that was published in 2018.
And nearly 30% of
that data generated
will be consumed in
real time by then.
So a huge opportunity,
huge amounts of data
being generated, and
that will continue
to drive costs using
traditional approaches.
And we know the cloud
market in general
is doubling over the
next several years.
The reality is only 5% of that
data that has been generated
so far has been analyzed.
So imagine the potential loss
of revenue, profitability,
and customer
satisfaction that could
have been realized if
organizations had put that data
to work, deriving
insights from it,
and accelerating time decision--
accelerating the decision
time using those insights.
And the last piece
here is the cloud--
given all this opportunity,
the cloud backup market,
according to market
research future report,
is also expected to grow to
nearly $5.6 billion dollars.
And that is driven by factors,
such as lower costs, greater
efficiencies, by
leveraging cloud backup
versus on-premises
backup solution, as well
as the adoption
of South solutions
and obviously the huge amounts
of data that's being derived.
So what does that mean from
your perspective and data
protection with Google Cloud?
First, as you've
heard this week,
the whole message is
all about modernizing
your infrastructure,
leveraging the innovations
that Google has that
we've made over the years,
and now we're applying
that and we're
looking to extend that business
continuity strategy that you
have built into Google
Cloud specifically
from a backup perspective.
And that is backing up
your on-premises workloads
to the cloud, as well as
backing up your cloud workloads,
and then archival
for the data tier,
tiering to different classes,
and lastly disaster recovery.
So again, extending
Google Cloud--
extending your business
continuity strategy into Google
Cloud, leveraging that
consistency that we have
in our storage classes-- and
we'll talk about that here
in a second--
to help reduce that
cost and, again,
take advantage of
the infrastructure
that basically that runs
Google.com search and Gmail as
well as Maps.
Now we're extending
that over, and we're
applying that same capability,
that same intelligence,
that same skill to the
backup and DR space as well.
In addition, from a
security perspective,
you heard Urs in his keynote
yesterday mention in a report
that Google Cloud was
rated the highest--
had the highest reliability
across any cloud provider
out there.
And that was not a report
that we commissioned.
That was a third-party
independent report.
And that speaks volumes
to the amount of security
that has built in--
that has been built in
by the Google engineers,
building up our infrastructure
to run our own business,
and again extending
that over to you
with encryption of data at
rest as well as in motion
and writing once and reading
many compliant storage.
So that's an important aspect
for the highly regulated
financial industries and
government public sector
and to be able to not alter
that data that's been archived,
as well as KMS and IM
integrations also available
in storage.
And then the last piece now that
you've leveraged Google Cloud
to backup an archive
of your data,
you're now able
to go and do more
with that, data leverage
those capabilities
that we have from an
AI and NL perspective
to achieve those desired
business outcomes.
As you saw in the
previous slide, only 5%
of the data that
has been generated
is being analyzed and actually
being taken advantage of.
This is an opportunity to
utilize the capabilities that
are built in, the
intelligence that
is built in within Google
Cloud to derive those insights
and leverage the capabilities
that we have with the TPUs
that we have that are 58 to 30%
faster than contemporary GPUs
and CPUs out there.
So from a storage perspective,
so as you're backing up
and you're archiving
your data into storage,
how many you heard
of the announcement
that we did yesterday around
the archive storage class?
All right, is that--
what do you guys think?
Good.
Awesome.
So it'll be available
later this year obviously,
but realize this
is the industry's
first online archived here--
online archived here.
So it's not cold per se.
It is cold storage, but
at the end of the day
it's available, all right.
So as you see here,
the price is going
to start $1.23 per
terabyte, again,
depending on your
regions and locations,
and there was a
session yesterday.
Hopefully, you guys attend that
as well around storage classes,
and that was recorded.
And you can go into
that a bit more.
But the main thing here is,
again, across all our storage
classes, you have a unified
experience because we provide
a single API for you to
integrate to our storage store
to that provides that consistent
performance across any
of the storage classes
regardless of the hotness
and coldness of
the class, as well
as the guaranteeing that listing
will always be up-to-date so
strongly consistent listing,
as well as it's scalable.
Again, it's scalable
because of what
we talked about earlier,
just that planet scale
infrastructure that we've built.
You saw in one of the keynotes
that we started out with two
Eiffel towers worth of scale,
and now we're was at
19 I think it was.
And it's just beginning,
and we launched
a couple of data centers
this week and a lot more
to come in the future.
So with that, we do like
[INAUDIBLE] earlier,
we have partnerships that we've
developed over the time that
are industry leaders in
the data protection space
and that cover different
types of use cases.
So the use cases again from
a backup perspective archive
and DR, partners can
have their solutions
solve problems for
you and customers
across these different needs.
And again, from a
backup perspective
we're differentiating
between backup of on-prem
to cloud workflows, as well
as cloud workflows in general.
And that's across any
cloud, by the way.
Again, back to that hybrid
and multi-cloud strategy,
we're taking that forward.
And the partners are
also working with us
to take that forward.
In addition, we
have partnerships
in the tape and transfer arena.
So think about all your
tape data that you have.
How do you take that data and
just sit back into the cloud--
into the cloud so
you can do what
you need to do with it and
then how do you transfer that?
So to give you context,
these are the partnerships
that we have.
We're very keen to
continue to grow
the partnerships to make sure
that we're meeting your needs.
I see a lot of
pictures, by the way.
All of these slides will
be available to everyone.
Feel free to take pictures, but
they will be available, as well
as a recording.
And my ask of all of you,
both customers and partners
in the room, if there
are solutions partners
that you are working with
that aren't up-- not up there,
please let us know.
Submit a question in the Dory
or grab us-- grab me afterwards,
and let's chat about
that for a minute.
So with that, let's hear from
our customers or partners.
What we're going to do is,
again, talk about cloud backup,
and we're going
to invite HYCU who
is one of our backup
as a service partners,
as well as Nubosoft, which
is going to-- they're
going to bring a unique
perspective into today's
conversation, because
they're not just a customer
but they're also a
Google Cloud Partner.
So they'll be able to
provide both the perspective.
As well as the archival and
backup of on-prem workload
use case with Cohesity
and Stanford Medicine,
and last but not least is
to talk about the disaster
recovery use case.
And we'll invite up
Actifio and ATB Financial.
So with that, let me
introduce and welcome
on stage Subbiah from haiku
HYCU and Santiago from Nubosoft.
[APPLAUSE]
So Subbiah you've
been in the industry
for a long time, data
protection space.
Welcome.
And Santiago, you
are the co-founder
of Nubosoft and the CTO.
And congratulations
on your win this week
as the Latin breakthrough
partner of the year.
So great job there.
Take it away.
So tell us a little bit
about your solution, what's
the benefit from a use case
perspective for the audience,
and then we'll hear a little
bit about the engagement
from your perspective.
SUBBIAH SUNDARAM:
Thank you, Bader.
First off, thank you very
much for inviting us.
Can you guys hear me?
Yeah.
Thank you very much for
inviting us to the show here.
First thing, let me tell you
about our company itself.
HYCU, we have been in business
for over 20 plus years.
Most people probably think
I've never heard of you,
because we used to be
in a different brand
and we rebranded ourself
about a year ago.
And as a company,
our focus is just
data protection and
monitoring that's what we do.
We have worked on at least
a different backup products
in the market today.
So from a engineering
strength perspective,
we have significant
capabilities here.
We have hundreds of
engineers specifically
focused on data protection,
and that's our core genesis
of the company.
And I think that's something
we really pride ourself off.
In some sense, my sales guys
sometime take offense of this.
We have more engineers than
salespeople in our company.
That's something which we do,
because it's a strength for us.
That's about the company itself.
Let me tell you about our focus.
As a company, our focus is to
build purpose built solutions
for every platform we choose.
And we are very happy that
we chose Google early on,
and I think we built a purpose
built solution for Google.
So that's-- I'll tell you more
about the solution itself,
but that's something we chose.
Because the reason
is that we believe
Google is an excellent
platform for partners
like us, number one,
and for great-- for you
guys, much better for
you guys actually.
So that's one of the
reasons we chose it,
and we have actually
it's purpose built
for the solution for that.
That's the second thing.
The third thing I
want to tell you about
is what are product
itself, right.
The product HYCU for GCP,
it's a fully managed service
we introduced
actually last July.
So it's been almost going to
be 9 plus months right now.
So we introduced last July.
It's been in the
marketplace, and we
have an excellent coverage
from our customers.
Our customers are very happy,
as well as some of our partners
who have been very
happy with the solution.
So you'll definitely hear
from Nubosoft more about it.
So people ask us so tell
us about why purpose built?
I explicitly said, it's
a purpose built solution.
People tell me
why purpose built?
What's special about it, right?
The key thing is
the way we think
about is Google as a platform
when you choose a platform we
believe backup and
recovery should
be an extended service
of the platform.
So that's why because when you
guys migrated your solutions
or services from your
on-prem onto cloud,
you wanted a cloud
native solution.
That's what you guys
are looking for.
So let me tell you a little bit
about some of the capabilities
we offer, and we'll
obviously be there later on
to even answer any question.
The first thing
it's a completely
born in the cloud solution.
Even though as a
company, we have
worked on many, many
solutions, right--
I mean, I've told you we've
been in business for a long time
and we had lots of IP--
we said when we
move to the cloud,
we said we have to
build a cloud native
solution because we wanted
you to have the Google Cloud
experience.
That's the fundamental thing.
That's the first thing.
The second thing, people
talk about scaled, right.
And we say elastic scale.
And the reason is that
Google as a platform
that's one of the things
they pride on, right.
It's the elastic scale nature.
Anytime you want to spin up
anything, turn off anything,
that's the model.
People say what is it
to do with the backup?
The reason for
elastic scale I say
is you can start with
just one virtual machine.
Subscribe for the
HYCU service, start
with just one virtual
machine, play it out,
we get comfortable,
and then expand it
to all your other projects.
That is something you can do.
The good thing you can even
turn down any of that stuff,
and we will only charge you--
similar to Google again--
we will only charge you for
just the things computer
use that particular day.
So it's a very second--
very aligned with the Google
philosophy there.
The third thing when we actually
started building our solution,
obviously, our
engineers have worked
on many different
products over the years.
So we asked them, guys, what
should we do differently
in the space apart from being
cloud and the cloud benefits?
They said, guys, we got to
make it simple and intelligent.
That's what they said.
And that has been
a big focus for us.
That's one of the reasons
to get up and running.
I would love to hear little but
of experience from Santiago,
but I'll tell you it's extremely
easy to get it up and running
and that's something
we pride on.
There's no agents
or configuration,
any of that stuff which
is required there.
So the simplicity
itself, you got
to extend that even to
all that user management.
Let's say what do
we mean by that?
So we are fully integrated
into the Google's identity
management.
I'm assuming all of you guys--
all of you guys are
Google customers here.
I'm sure all of you guys
set up your infrastructure
and your users and ad
privileges in Google IAM.
The good thing is that once
you set up in Google IAM
and there is nothing
you got to do in HYCU,
HYCU automatically inherits all
of the setup you have actually
done there.
So there is no extra management.
The reason this is
actually important
when you guys decided to
move to the cloud, people who
are managing your
infrastructure,
predominantly your server
and application people
are the ones who
move to the cloud.
You don't carry a backup
administrator to the cloud.
Very rarely do you
do that, right.
So that's one of the reasons we
wanted to make sure it's simple
and it is built for
the cloud admin.
And it is for built for
people who are actually
the regular users of the cloud
infrastructure, not necessarily
a backup administrator.
It's a fundamental
philosophy thing,
but that is something I think
would make your life lot more
easier in the longer run.
So the thing also
if you talk about
is that from an infrastructure
perspective, once you've
decided to Google
you are actually
building-- we wanted to make
sure our entire even building
is integrated with Google.
So that's where when you
look at your, as I said,
it's a backup as an extension
of your platform, right.
So if you wanted to make
sure that's fully there,
and it is something
you will actually
see it HYCU when you use HYCU.
Some of the other things I
wanted to probably mention
is that I talk to you
about elastic scale.
It's completely scales out.
The thing about HYCU is
that people sometimes
ask me saying why
should I choose HYCU?
I bring in myself I
ask them saying, why
did you choose Google first?
I asked them the question.
The biggest things I
hear from customers
is it's simple,
scalable, and secure.
That's what we hear from
customers, some of the topics
Bader mentioned earlier.
I said that's exactly the
reason you choose HYCU.
So again, that's me talking.
So you probably
are thinking that I
keep talking about [INAUDIBLE].
I think I should probably
hear from Nubusoft.
One last thing I'll tell you
before I actually hand it
off to Santiago to give
you more information.
I talked a lot about the backup
and how our infrastructure
is at the end of the day
you're doing backup only
for recovery purpose, right.
So we've got to give you a
light level of granularity,
and that is something
built into HYCU.
You can do a file
level, a folder level,
the different levels of
databases, and so on.
And in case you guys
are using Cloud SQL,
we actually announced
support for Cloud SQL
just earlier this week.
So that is something you
should be [INAUDIBLE],,
please do let us and
stop by our booth
and we can give you
more information.
So let me actually
stop here and actually
pass it on to Santiago.
As Bade said, Santiago
is an interesting--
it was a very interesting
experience working
with Santiago here.
They are the partner--
the Google Partner
of the Year in Latin America.
That's a fantastic thing.
And the thing is
that they're just
not a partner who is actually
selling it to other customers.
They also are a
consumer of the service.
So I would love to hear
Santiago give his experience.
Santiago?
SANTIAGO JIMENEZ ABAD:
Hi, thank you, Subbiah.
Bader, thank you for
the introduction.
My name is Santiago.
I'm the CTO for Nubusoft.
As you guys heard, we are a
Mexican Google Cloud partner.
We've been a partner
for eight years now.
We started with G
Suite a long time ago.
Now we've been working with
GCP for over two years.
We have hundreds of clients.
And one characteristic
of Nubosoft
is we are a really
automated company.
We are only 20 people, and
we have over 2000 clients.
We also have a great
engineering team internally.
So this was getting troublesome.
We had many, many
clients, and our engineers
were working on this, on having
a really good backup solution.
What we were doing before is
we were working with scripts.
We were working
with other tools.
We had already talked
to Google about this,
and we couldn't find a way
to easily solve this problem.
So one day we received
an email from HYCU.
We had a call, and
the amazing thing
was in five minutes we had
our first company set up.
That was us, OK.
We were the first ones
to work with HYCU,
and in only five minutes
we had a backup recovery,
a great dashboard
that we could look at.
Customers could log in, as
you said, with Google's IAM.
It was integrated
with Google billing,
so that make it even easier.
And then we decided,
OK, we're going
to talk to the first customers.
So one customer, two customer,
three customers, and they
were all amazed by what
we could do with HYCU.
So now we had a
point in time backup.
We have a fully managed
application level
integrated backup.
We had it securely with
a lot of flexibility,
and it was reliable.
And so far we've implemented
dozens of clients at Nubosoft.
We get a new HYCU customer
every couple of days,
because as I mentioned, we
work with hundreds of clients.
And so far it's been
an amazing solution.
So after the presentation,
we're going to have a little QA.
If you guys have
any questions, I
think I'm going to
hand it over to Bader.
Thank you.
BADER HAMDAN: Thank
you, Santiago.
Thank you, Subbiah.
So our next set of
speakers are going
to be covering our archival
and on-prem backup use case.
So with that, I'm going to
invite Christian onstage, who
is the VP of product
marketing at Cohesity,
and Hans, who is the director of
platform services from Stanford
Medicine.
So Hans runs the services--
reliable, secure services
for Stanford for
the past 13 years,
and we're going to hear
more about that industry
and his experience when it
comes to backup and archive.
So with that, hand it
over to you Christian.
CHRISTIAN PAULUS: All right.
Thank you, Bader.
Cohesity addresses the problem
of mass data fragmentation.
So let me explain to you
what this actually mean.
So you probably have hundreds
or thousands of applications
and you backup
those applications,
the data of those applications
into your storage silos.
And you probably have 5, 6, 7
different management vendors
to do this job.
So all of this
becomes very complex.
So there's a lot of
organizational and IT
complexity in here.
And then you probably
take copies of this data.
You probably take 10
copies of this data
or perhaps even more for use
cases like test dev and so on.
And so this really increases
just the inefficiency
of having all of this data
across your organization.
And then lastly, this
data now is so fragmented
and dispersed across
your organization,
you probably don't even
know what data you have
and where you have those,
and so this exposes you
to compliance risks.
So we are addressing
this kind of problem--
this problem of mass data
fragmentation with a single web
scale platform,
which spans to cloud
but also on-premises
and end points.
And what we do
here, we consolidate
all of this complexity into a
single platform for use cases,
such as backup, archiving,
disaster recovery, and also
test dev and a few
other use cases.
And you can also download from
our marketplace applications
to address use cases like
anti-ransomware or compliance
applications, which then
help you to actually get more
value all of your backup data.
So we radically simplify
backup and recovery
through this single
consolidated platform,
and we provide capabilities here
like policy-driven automation,
which allows you to eliminate
scripting and manual processes.
We provide Google-like
search, which
allows you to identify
and search and recover
individual files or VMs.
And lastly, we do all of this
by greatly reducing your data
footprint.
And we are using here features
like global variable lengthy
deduplication and compression.
So as I mentioned before,
we do this across the cloud
on-premises and endpoints.
But just two days ago, we
launched a new service here
at Google Next.
So it's called Cohesity
cloud backup service.
So this is very exciting.
That's a backup as a service.
And specifically, it
provides enterprise grade
backup and recovery
for applications
running in the Google Cloud.
But today, we really want to
focus on the hybrid use case.
And also here we
make it very easy
and seamless to integrate
into the Google Cloud.
And here I would like to hand
over to Hans from Google--
from the Stanford
medical school.
HANS JACOBSEN:
Thanks, Christian.
Thanks, Bader.
As mentioned, I've been
with Stanford Medicine
for over 13 years.
That's a long time at an
organization in the Bay Area.
Let me tell you a little
background as to why.
So the School of Medicine
has missions in education,
research, and patient care.
And Stanford Medicine is on
the forefront of digital health
and precision medicine.
So it's really exciting.
And Stanford's mission
goes beyond the boundaries
of Stanford.
We care about health
care around the world.
I'll just give you one example.
There's a pediatrics
research team
that runs a program for
the state of California
that's saving nearly 1,000 lives
a year in California alone,
and that program is
expanding beyond California.
And I'm just sitting here
going, OK, me and my team
we do what we know how to do.
The researchers do their
work and get things
into clinical practice.
And in 20 years, there will
be nearly 20,000 people
alive who wouldn't have been.
So that's just a really
compelling mission to me.
So those two things
together keep me in place,
helping new things happen.
So our platform services
team is 20 folks,
and I'll tell you a little
bit more about what we are.
We have about 110 critical
and important services.
I mean, we run
hundreds of services.
But there's about 110
that are critical.
We have 75 distinct customer
groups, and that's complexity.
We're, sort of, a little
non-profit business
inside Stanford.
And we have somewhere between
650 and 700 server instances,
mostly virtual.
We have about 120 databases.
And on-prem, we manage about a
quarter of a petabyte of data.
So what's our problem?
What were we trying to do?
So backup and archive is
just a critical service.
It's probably the most
critical service we offer.
We cannot lose data.
We have all of the patients
and researchers and faculty
who depend on us to keep
the data safe and secure,
private and available.
We also with our
business model have
to transparently pass costs
of our archive storage
at Google onto our customer
groups at Stanford.
And so we have to use lots
of different Google projects.
That's the easiest
way for us to do that.
We have all the complex
backup and archive needs
of the large enterprise.
With all the virtual
machines, I mentioned,
we have bare metal systems, lots
of local centralized storage
systems, as well as lots of
different operating systems
and database technologies.
We maintained an aging
tape backup solution.
It worked, but it
kept many people busy
safely and securely
handling a lot of tapes,
and with it we
felt like we needed
to do lots of full backups
all the time, which
really puts a load on
our production system.
So it's not ideal, but we were
waiting for the right partner
to work with our
strategic cloud partner
Google to help us move forward.
And when Cohesity GA
at Google Next 2018,
we started working
with them right away.
So all those folks need us to
have those dependable backups.
And we felt like we had
to backup the cloud.
With the 11 nines of durability
for the storage that Google
provides, that's just
better than anything
we could do on-prem.
And I would say that
both Cohesity and Google
with the encryption at rest
and at transit, they were
meeting our security needs.
So Cohesity provides
a fully modern backup
and archive solution.
We have agents where needed
with our bare metal systems,
but we have deep
and full integration
with our virtual
machine infrastructure
and direct interfacing with
our central storage solutions.
And so that's just so
many steps forward for us.
And Cohesity's fully
hydrated incremental backups
let us do full backups
much less often, much
less load on our
production systems.
And they're letting us use
all the Google projects
we might want to use,
and it's really easy.
And that's fantastic.
The recovery of data with
Cohesity is excellent.
I'd say we really
like the ability
to immediately recover a virtual
machine from that local storage
while we move back to normal
operations, and the cloud
capability--
the recoveries there are
just frankly much faster
than I would have ever expected.
We have about 3/4
of petabytes now
archived on Google
Cloud and growing.
I also want to say that our
partnership with Cohesity,
I mean, I appreciate it.
We have a very complex, nuanced,
security infrastructure on-prem
with like dozens of VLANs.
And we've had other people we've
talked to in industry basically
say, don't do that.
That's complicated.
And we feel like
we have to, so I
appreciate that Cohesity's
helped us make that work.
So we're happy with the
solution we have now,
but we also look to the future.
So Cohesity's features and
security and multi-tenancy,
we are looking
forward to testing
letting other partners
in the School of Medicine
who have systems we're
not centrally managing use
our cohesive system right
alongside us securely
and safely, and that's great.
And the future with possibly
using hybrid and DR solutions,
we've already got the
data archived out there.
If there was some
kind of catastrophe,
it would be really great to be
able to use that for a disaster
recovery solution.
So we'll be testing that.
I'm also very interested in the
just announced very low cost,
long-term archive solution
that Google announced.
We're using cold
line storage, and we
think that is very cost
effective and performing
very well for us.
But lower cost, we're
very sensitive to costs.
So we care a lot about that, and
I appreciate that announcement.
That was a surprise.
BADER HAMDAN: Just for
you guys this week.
HANS JACOBSEN: Thank you.
And I'll look forward to
answering any questions
you have afterwards.
BADER HAMDAN: Thank you, Hans.
Thank you, Christian.
Appreciate it.
All right, so now we'll talk
about disaster recovery use
case and how to leverage
our partnership with Actifio
and ATB Financial also taking
advantage of that capability.
So onstage please
welcome Patrick,
who is an account executive
for two years Actifio
and covers the New
England and Canada market,
and I hear he's a
decent guy as well.
So and then Matt is from ATB,
the manager of the database
and infrastructure at ATB.
And in his own words--
guys, this is his own words--
he's a jack of all trades
and a master of as few
as he can get away with.
I am so taking that.
So with that, I hand
it off to you guys.
PATRICK O'NEIL: Thank you.
My name is Patrick.
I'm a decent guy I would say,
but we appreciate you guys
having us here today and
all attending the session.
So Actifio, we are
founded in 2009,
and we've grown
into a company who
has over 3,000 customers
around the globe.
Our partnership with Google
has grown exponentially
over the past year
especially and introduced us
to great people like Matt
and the team over here.
So what Actifio does, I'll
give you a little spill on us
and then let Matt talk for
the majority of the time.
But what Actifio does
is we enable enterprises
to deliver enterprise
data as a service on-prem
or in any of the public
clouds, specifically focusing
on Google for Matt's use case.
So what that means
is we're really
focused on three key area, and
the first one is going to be
an incremental forever backup.
So Actifio supports
a wide variety
of mission critical applications
and databases, Oracle, SQL,
SAP Hana, MySQL
Postgres, et cetera.
And we're going to take
an initial ingest of all
of your applications and
databases on day one.
Then the end user is going
to create a policy where
he tells us he wants just those
change walks captured every six
hours, for example.
And then we're going to roll
those changes into our master
copy.
And what this does is it allows
our second use case disaster
recovery where we
actually are allowing
ATB to have our virtual Actifio
appliance in one region of GCP
and replicating over to
a second region in GCP
where they can actually
spin up in a disaster
scenario a
multi-terabyte mission
critical databases in a matter
of two to three minutes.
So our third use case--
and it kind flows back
into the initial ingest
I was talking about--
is that test data
management use case.
So Actifio was founded, and
we thought we're already
taking these back ups.
So why don't we just reuse these
backups that we already have.
So what we allow you
to do is provision
out multiple copies for
dev test, staging, QA,
UAT in virtual format
only taking a matter
of two to three minutes.
And they're all just
using the pointers
to point back to our
Actifio golden copy,
so they're not consuming
any additional displace.
So it's great for
Matt and the team.
We were able to help them
replicate from one region
to the other for
multi-terabyte databases
and give them the security
in a disaster scenario
to kind of be back up and
running in a matter of minutes.
But also for their
DR capabilities,
test that in a
protected environment.
So I'm going to turn
it over to Matt.
I appreciate you guys
coming today, and--
MATTHEW PETRIE:
Thank you, Patrick.
Thank you, Bader.
Just before I get
started, I just
want to thank or
apologize to Patrick
that my Blue Jays ruined
the Red Sox home opener.
I'm sorry, but not really sorry.
So thank you everyone
for coming this morning.
So ATB Financial is a 5,500
employee financial institution
that provides financial
services to people
in the province of Alberta.
So we are bounded by, kind
of, the geographical location
that we're in.
In late 2016, we embarked
upon a transformation.
And as part of this
transformation,
we were focused on innovation
and collaboration, which
led us to adopt G Suite and
then partner with Google
for our journey to the Cloud,
so to be a GCP consumer.
It was part of this-- it
was this getting started
on the journey to GCP that
made us realize that as an SAP
partner, we were going to be
exposed to new technologies,
HANA, Sybase--
new to us technologies
that we were going to need
or that we would
benefit from a solution
of how we could back
them up and protect them.
Excuse me.
So we partner with
Actifio, because we
were able to cover our backup
needs which were system state,
file system backups, as well
as any of the new database
platforms that were part of
our journey to the cloud.
We were mindful of our
costs, and what we really
appreciate being a leverage
is the snapshot technology
that Actifio
provides that allows
us to use efficient cold line
disk that really helps us
manage our costs in the cloud.
We are also a company that has
experienced a data center loss,
and so after having that
real life DR opportunity,
ATB has put a special
focus on having
a very resilient and capable
DR solution, which brings us
to the second part of our
partnership with Actifio,
which is being able to leverage
their technologies to protect
us in the event of losing a
region in GCP, which I know
will never happen
Bader but just in case.
We also appreciate the ability
to test that DR capability
in a protected
environment, which
makes our DR exercises that
much more easy to simulate
and takes much less
time and manpower to do.
And so while our GCP
landscape right now
is still fairly small,
it's growing quickly.
And what we've appreciated
is the scalability
and the ease with which we've
been able to expand our sky
appliances, add sky appliances.
So it means that we don't have
to over provision to start,
which the people who dole
out the money at ATB really
appreciate.
Yeah, so I mean
that's it for me.
So please I'll be happy to
answer or talk any questions,
and I'll pass it back to Bader.
Thank you.
BADER HAMDAN: Thank
you guys so much.
Appreciate it.
All right, homestretch,
it's the last day.
It's the last part of
this conversation here.
Hopefully, you now
have a bit more insight
into the different use cases for
data protection in Google Cloud
from hearing from our
partners and customers today.
So to wrap it up,
today we've discussed
how data is continuing
to grow and how
cloud backup as an opportunity
is a growing requirement
and how you can leverage
Google Cloud as an extension
of your business
continuity strategy
for backup, archive,
and disaster recovery,
again, helping you leveraging
the capabilities that we have
that we spoke about to lower
your RTOs and RPOs, as well
as leverage that innovation,
the security, reliability,
and again that planet
scale infrastructure
and differentiation
that we bring and we're
extending to you are our
customers and partners.
As you saw, we have a large
data protection partnership
ecosystem, and it
continues to grow.
And they bring those
integral components
from a data
protection perspective
enabling those BADR use cases.
This is not a term that
we're going to coin though.
So we look to leverage,
again, Google Cloud as--
this is a different cloud,
as you heard this week.
Our theme is Google Cloud is
a different kind of Cloud,
and it will allow organizations
basically to focus.
We want to allow you
to focus on your--
growing your business and less
about administering and running
all these legacy from a
backup [INAUDIBLE] perspective
capabilities,
leveraging the cloud
to go and do backup,
do disaster recovery,
and let us Google Cloud
and our cloud partners
to take care of those
data protection needs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]